Shure:  白塔在北京的普及率好高
Shure: The White Pagoda is really popular in Beijing.
Lucia: 说地域笑话
Lucia: Making regional jokes.
Jake:至少在这密度极大
Jake: At least the density is very high here.
Katrina:  我今天没带美甲
Katrina: I didn't bring my nail polish today.
Katrina:  我也不要钱
Katrina: I don't want any money either.
Katrina:  随便走吧
Katrina: Let's just go.
Alice:今天18吗
Alice: Is it the 18th today?
Lucia: 对 18
Lucia: Yeah, the 18th.
Lucia: （歌词）sure were the things just to get out of it
Lucia: (lyrics) Sure were the things just to get out of it.
Lucia: 我听到这首歌里面如果有需要
Lucia: I hear this song, if there's a need...
Lucia: 如果不是如果
Lucia: If not, if...
Lucia: 有一些需要和谐的词汇的话
Lucia: If there are some words that need to be censored...
Lucia: 你们会码掉吗
Lucia: Will you guys bleep them out?
Lucia: 比如说f word这些的
Lucia: Like the f-word, for example.
Jake:可能不会吧
Jake: Probably not.
Lucia: 啊这样吗
Lucia: Oh, really?
Jake:这不管了管不了那么多
Jake: We don't really care about that.
Alice:采集一下牡丹
Alice: Let's collect some peonies.
Lucia:（歌词） got feelings they only hear you say
Lucia: (lyrics) Got feelings they only hear you say...
Alice:漂亮好喜欢
Alice: Beautiful, I love it.
Alice:哦开的真好
Alice: Oh, they bloomed so well.
Jake: 原来我有一个帽子
Jake: I actually have a hat.
Jake: 我也觉得我没有戴帽子
Jake: I thought I wasn't wearing a hat.
Jake: 结果是有帽子
Jake: Turns out I am.
Lucia: 其实你也可以在上面再戴一个
Lucia: You can actually wear another one on top.
Tasha:  你摄像头不带吗
Tasha: Aren't you taking your camera?
Jake:戴
Jake: I am.
Jake: 他总共能录的不久
Jake: It can't record for long.
Lucia: 哦这个地方好像北大
Lucia: Oh, this place looks like Peking University.
Lucia: 救命哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Help, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈确实
Jake: Hahaha, it really does.
Alice:未名湖呃
Alice: It's like Weiming Lake.
Lucia: 对啊那个塔也很像伯牙塔
Lucia: Yeah, that tower looks like Boya Tower too.
Alice:通州分湖
Alice: Tongzhou Branch Lake.
Lucia: 比伯牙塔那个塔尖高一点
Lucia: But the spire is a bit taller.
Jake: 对通州分塔通州分塔
Jake: Yeah, Tongzhou Branch Tower, Tongzhou Branch Tower.
Alice:这是芬塔哈哈
Alice: This is Fenta, haha.
Jake: 通州分塔
Jake: Tongzhou Branch Tower.
Jake: 没什么人
Jake: There's no one here.
Jake: 所以很适合跳舞
Jake: So it's perfect for dancing.
Jake: 有道理吧
Jake: Makes sense, right?
Tasha:  你也跳一跳你就知道了
Tasha: You should try dancing and you'll know.
Jake: 哈哈哈就知道有多
Jake: Hahaha, then you'll know how...
Lucia: 这种剪辑出来很像抖音上那种尬舞
Lucia: This kind of editing looks like those awkward dances on TikTok.
Lucia: 就是我说那种突然开始跳舞的那种
Lucia: You know, the ones where they suddenly start dancing.
Jake: 啊啊啊是
Jake: Yeah, yeah, totally.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:有小鱼好多
Alice: There are so many little fish.
Lucia: 也不是不行
Lucia: Yeah, it's not impossible.
Alice:啊小鱼苗
Alice: Ah, the baby fish.
Alice:好啥呀
Alice: So many of them.
Tasha:  跑啥
Tasha: Why are they running?
Alice:好多啊
Alice: There are so many.
Jake: 哪了
Jake: Where?
Alice:就是那种特别小的
Alice: Just those really tiny ones.
Alice:很多然后那种
Alice: A lot of them, and like...
Jake: 在蹦跶是吧
Jake: They're hopping around, right?
Lucia: 小锦鲤吗
Lucia: Little koi fish?
Alice:对对对然后还有那种有颜色的
Alice: Yeah, yeah, and there are colorful ones too.
Jake: 还小王八
Jake: And little turtles.
Jake: 我看到了
Jake: I saw them.
Lucia: 哎我看到了
Lucia: Oh, I see them.
Jake: 对小王八小鱼
Jake: Yeah, little turtles and fish.
Alice:然后这些小小的全是特别小的鱼苗
Alice: And all these tiny ones, they're all baby fish.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 哈哈为什么不是小乌龟
Lucia: Haha, why not call them little turtles?
Alice:好多好多
Alice: So many, so many.
Jake: 这小乌龟
Jake: These little turtles.
Alice:小王八
Alice: Little turtles.
Lucia: 王八和乌龟是一种吗
Lucia: Are turtles and terrapins the same?
Lucia: 王八是甲鱼还是什么
Lucia: Is a terrapin a kind of turtle or what?
Jake: 应该是哦
Jake: I think so.
Jake: 是吗我也不知道
Jake: Is it? I'm not sure.
Lucia: 我不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 我也不知道啊
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 好吧那我们就姑且认为是同一种吧
Lucia: Okay, let's just assume they are the same.
Jake: 对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 这里面好多鱼啊
Lucia: There are so many fish here.
Alice:好多好多
Alice: So many, so many.
Lucia: 好多人啊哈哈
Lucia: So many people, haha
Jake: 是说钓鱼啦钓
Jake: I mean fishing, fishing
Jake: 鼓掌有什么用
Jake: What's the point of clapping?
Jake: 鼓掌有什么用啊
Jake: 啊真的吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Jake: 鱼鱼鱼它鱼它有耳朵是吗
Jake: Fish, fish, do they have ears?
Jake: 哦这么个音波是吧
Jake: Oh, it's about the sound waves, right?
Katrina:  这个抛的很准
Katrina: That was a perfect cast.
Shure:  这素材够用吧
Shure: Is this footage enough?
Katrina:  这老北京鱼翅达美乐呀
Katrina: This is like old Beijing fish fin Domino's.
Shure:  全吞了
Shure: Swallowed it whole.
Katrina:  地道道哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Authentic, hahaha
Alice:地地地地道
Alice: So, so authentic.
Jake: 呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehe
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Shure:  天嘀嗒地嘀嗒滴答滴滴答
Shure: Tik-tok, tik-tok, tick tick-tock
Shure:  滴滴答滴滴答
Shure: Tick tick-tock, tick tick-tock
Shure:  我饿了想吃了
Shure: I'm hungry, I want to eat.
Shure:  在这
Shure: Here it is.
Jake: 和鱼一起吃
Jake: Eat with the fish.
Katrina:  开吃才走两步
Katrina: Just started eating and already walked two steps.
Tasha:  太大了
Tasha: It's too big.
Jake: 确实很离谱
Jake: It really is ridiculous.
Jake: 这个数据确实
Jake: These numbers are really...
Jake: 不知道为什么能看成这个样子
Jake: Don't know why it can look like this.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈闻所未闻哈
Jake: Hahaha, never heard of it, haha
Alice:海风往这边吹
Alice: The sea breeze is blowing this way.
Alice:他非得往那边游
Alice: Yet he insists on swimming that way.
Alice:他还游不动
Alice: And he can't swim.
Shure:  我们如果太偏离人类的正常情况的话
Shure: If we deviate too much from normal human conditions...
Tasha:  这离上岸得多远啊
Tasha: How far are we from the shore?
Jake: 哈哈好挺好的
Jake: Haha, it's quite good.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈不如随波逐流吧
Alice: Hahaha, might as well go with the flow.
Tasha:  我的妈呀
Tasha: Oh my god.
Tasha:  我真不敢想
Tasha: I really can't imagine.
Lucia: AI应该知道人类并不一直是理性人
Lucia: AI should know that humans aren't always rational.
Shure:  会污染
Shure: It will cause pollution.
Katrina:  啊人类
Katrina: Oh, humans.
Jake: 是是是你也很特殊
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, you're very special too.
Katrina:  这就是AI永远无法取取代人类的原因
Katrina: This is why AI can never replace humans.
Jake: 对哎呀不好意思不好意思
Jake: Right, oh sorry, sorry.
Lucia: 虽然我知道
Lucia: Although I know...
Lucia: 经济学家也老假设人类是理性人
Lucia: Economists always assume humans are rational.
Katrina:  因为人类总会做一些莫名其妙的行为
Katrina: Because humans always do some inexplicable things.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina:  这就是人类
Katrina: This is humanity.
Jake: 局部是有逻辑的好吧
Jake: In parts, it's logical, alright.
Alice:AI无法理解的
Alice: Something AI can't understand.
Jake: 局部上是有
Jake: In parts, it is.
Jake: 就是你扔出去
Jake: Like when you throw out...
Alice:超多小小小小小鱼苗
Alice: A lot of tiny, tiny, tiny fish fry.
Jake: 然后鱼吃披萨
Jake: And then the fish eat pizza.
Lucia: 嗯啊那么小的也有竟然
Lucia: Hmm, even the tiny ones do that.
Jake: 然后你看到鱼真披萨
Jake: And then you see the fish eating pizza.
Alice:对就超级超级小的
Alice: Yeah, they're super, super small.
Jake: 这个多少是有一点点过去了
Jake: This is a bit in the past now.
Katrina:  yes
Katrina: Yes.
Jake: 虽然不多
Jake: Though not much.
Jake: 这些鱼应该什么都吃
Jake: These fish should eat everything.
Jake: 公园里的鱼都是杂食类的鱼
Jake: The fish in the park are omnivores.
Jake: 鱼肉会吃吗
Jake: Do they eat fish meat?
Jake: 有应该会
Jake: They probably do.
Lucia: 妈呀
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Jake: 应该他们会互相吃
Jake: They probably eat each other.
Shure:  废话我们刚刚看了那个
Shure: Well, we just saw that.
Lucia: 大鱼吃小鱼是吧
Lucia: Big fish eat small fish, right?
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Shure:  发现海里鱼都是在吃自己的东西
Shure: We found that fish in the sea are eating their own kind.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  然后评论难道猪能在海里吗哈哈哈
Shure: Then someone commented, can pigs be in the sea? Hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈在海里的不都鱼吗哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha, aren't all the things in the sea fish? Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice:颐和园的大雁都还挑食呢
Alice: Even the geese in the Summer Palace are picky eaters.
Jake: 这都吃完了
Jake: They've eaten all of this.
Jake: 哈哈哈这都吃完了这个
Jake: Hahaha, they've eaten all of this.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Alice:什么都吃
Alice: Eat everything
Lucia: 还有一块呢
Lucia: There's another piece
Tasha:  在湖边喂喂鱼
Tasha: Feeding the fish by the lake
Jake: 喂人喂鱼
Jake: Feed people, feed fish
Shure:  外边外边
Shure: Outside, outside
Shure:  自己画的
Shure: I drew it myself
Katrina:  那我把这块吃了
Katrina: Then I'll eat this piece
Jake: 对啊一会要有海鸥怎么办
Jake: Yeah, what if there are seagulls later?
Jake: 还有东西喂吗
Jake: Is there still something to feed them?
Tasha:  麦当劳整点薯条
Tasha: Get some fries from McDonald's
Lucia: 盒子里还有点渣
Lucia: There's still some crumbs in the box
Jake: 还有还有
Jake: There's more, there's more
Jake: 还有点渣
Jake: There's still some crumbs
Alice:海鸥找点薯条喂他
Alice: Find some fries to feed the seagulls
Lucia: 去码头整点薯条
Lucia: Go to the dock and get some fries
Jake: 还有点鸡肉
Jake: There's still some chicken
Jake: 可以给他留着
Jake: We can save it for them
Alice: 这个可以扔一下吗
Alice: Can I throw this?
Jake: 哦还有一盒好
Jake: Oh, there's still a box, alright
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈哈抛洒
Lucia: Ah hahaha, sprinkle it around
Jake: 哦哦有存货
Jake: Oh oh, there's still some stock
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 骨灰哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ashes, hahahaha
Lucia: 披萨也可以算是种面子的骨灰是吧
Lucia: Pizza could be considered a type of ashes, right?
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right
其他人：这算一种码头啊
Others: This could be considered a dock, right?
Jake: 对小码头
Jake: Yeah, a small dock
Jake: 这叫什么胡啊
Jake: What's this lake called?
Jake: 有名字吗
Jake: Does it have a name?
Alice:未名湖
Alice: Unnamed Lake
Lucia: 未名湖
Lucia: Unnamed Lake
Jake: 好哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Alright, hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina:  哎呀又疑惑了哈哈
Katrina: Ah, I'm confused again, haha
Tasha:  难道是我扔的不够远吗
Tasha: Was it because I didn't throw it far enough?
Lucia: 用AI识图识别这一块儿为北大是吗
Lucia: Use AI to identify this place as Peking University, right?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 这边可以预测哪只鱼可以吃得到
Jake: Here, you can predict which fish you can catch.
Tasha:  我知道如果抢的话就会吃的香
Tasha: I know if you grab it, it will taste better.
Tasha:  哈哈你看我的在那后面就不是吃
Tasha: Haha, see mine at the back, it’s not eating.
Lucia: 这么神奇
Lucia: That's amazing.
Katrina:  抛物线
Katrina: Parabola.
Tasha:  必须要抢才行
Tasha: You have to grab it.
Katrina:  落点位置
Katrina: Landing spot.
Shure:  你想落哪我就能落哪
Shure: Wherever you want it to land, I can make it land.
Shure:  看那边去了
Shure: Look, it went over there.
Tasha:  哇太小了
Tasha: Wow, that's too small.
Tasha:  他们不吃
Tasha: They won't eat it.
Tasha:  你看开始抢着开始吃了
Tasha: See, they started grabbing and eating it.
Katrina:  问一下AI那是活的
Katrina: Ask the AI if it's alive.
Shure:  那是活的吗
Shure: Is it alive?
Katrina:  那富二代吧
Katrina: It's probably a rich kid.
Jake: 啊还有死的呀
Jake: Oh, there are dead ones too?
Shure:  那是条大海鱼
Shure: That's a big sea fish.
Lucia: 那是鱼吧
Lucia: That's a fish, right?
Jake: 那那个
Jake: And that one...
Jake: 就那飘着的吗
Jake: The one floating there?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Katrina:  哎我去
Katrina: Oh my gosh.
Jake: 这风有点大
Jake: The wind is a bit strong.
Jake: 试试
Jake: Let’s try it.
Alice:哎什么掉了
Alice: Hey, what fell?
Katrina:  手串
Katrina: A bracelet.
Tasha:  东西掉了
Tasha: Something fell.
Lucia: 没有是鱼
Lucia: No, it's a fish.
Lucia: 那个翻滚的声音
Lucia: That sound of flipping.
Katrina:  手串吗
Katrina: A bracelet?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Tasha:  他的手链断了
Tasha: His bracelet broke.
Alice:真的假的
Alice: Really?
Katrina:  完了被女朋友骂死
Katrina: Oh no, his girlfriend is going to kill him.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 掉哪去了
Jake: Where did it fall?
Tasha:  掉到湖里了
Tasha: It fell into the lake.
Alice:未名湖里
Alice: In Weiming Lake
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake: 掉未名湖了
Jake: Fell into Weiming Lake
Jake: 他自己应该记得吧
Jake: He should remember it himself, right?
Katrina:  我的眼镜应该看到了
Katrina: My glasses probably saw it
Jake: 你自己也记了
Jake: You remembered it yourself too
Shure:  没救了
Shure: No hope
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina:  滑动摩擦力太小了
Katrina: The sliding friction is too low
Alice:好像也不是很深
Alice: Doesn't seem too deep
Alice:要不提供点珍贵素材
Alice: How about providing some valuable footage?
Lucia: 人类早期下水捕鱼素材
Lucia: Early human fishing footage
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure
Shure:  那怎么还就剩鱼头了呢
Shure: Then why is there only a fish head left?
Tasha:  我靠
Tasha: Oh my god
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Jake: 呃应该是被吃了嗯
Jake: Uh, it should've been eaten, yeah
Tasha:  应该是被大鱼吃小鱼的时候吃掉了
Tasha: Probably got eaten by a bigger fish
Tasha:  那头鱼不喜欢吃鱼头
Tasha: That fish doesn't like eating fish heads
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Alice:他应该吃鱼身子吧
Alice: It probably eats the body, not the head
Alice:他不吃鱼头
Alice: It doesn't eat the head
Jake: 是鱼头没什么肉不好吃
Jake: The fish head doesn't have much meat, not tasty
Katrina:  准备好回去下跪吧搓衣板
Katrina: Get ready to kneel on the washboard when we get back
Alice:我靠真是鱼
Alice: Oh my god, it's really a fish
Lucia: 啊什么呀
Lucia: What?
Jake: 或者是别的一些生物
Jake: Or maybe some other creatures
Jake: NPU那边有水獭
Jake: There are otters in NPU
Jake: 水獭吃鱼
Jake: Otters eat fish
Lucia: 有什么奇怪景象吗
Lucia: Any strange scenes?
Jake: 吃一半就丢路边
Jake: Eat half and leave it by the road
Lucia: 让我的让我的眼睛也看一看哈哈
Lucia: Let my eyes have a look too, haha
Lucia: 什么呀
Lucia: What?
Alice:你看那看见没
Alice: Look there, did you see?
Alice:鱼已经泡发白了
Alice: The fish has turned white from soaking
Alice:那个鱼的眼睛睁的贼大
Alice: The fish's eyes are wide open
Lucia: 好可怕
Lucia: So scary
Shure: 上哪捞去呀
Shure: Where to fish it up?
Lucia: 没就是我没绕过来之前
Lucia: No, it's just that before I came around,
Lucia: 我以为那是一片塑料
Lucia: I thought it was a piece of plastic.
Jake: 你问问问问有没有那大网子是吧
Jake: Ask if there's a big net, right?
Shure: 不用捞
Shure: No need to scoop it up.
Jake: 在哪啊沉进去了
Jake: Where is it? It sank.
Jake: 那一片是吧
Jake: That piece, right?
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 嗯吼
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 跟鱼头在一块差不多
Jake: It's almost with the fish head.
Tasha:  就在鱼头附近
Tasha: Near the fish head.
Jake: 让鱼头看看让鱼头看看
Jake: Let the fish head take a look.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 去下一个景点
Jake: To the next spot.
Jake: 这是什么景点
Jake: What's this spot?
Tasha:  湖边喂鱼景点
Tasha: The lakeside fish feeding spot.
Jake: 这叫什么
Jake: What's it called?
Alice:说明他完成了他的使命
Alice: It means he's completed his mission.
Shure:  完了这不会是哥我家附近吧
Shure: Oh no, could this be near my place?
Alice:帮你躲过一灾
Alice: He helped you avoid a disaster.
Tasha:  要一个清水平台区吧
Tasha: We need a clear water platform area, right?
Tasha:  下一个区
Tasha: Next area.
其他人：是一个珠子的残骸吗
Others: Is it a bead remnant?
Shure:  有一个能交代就行
Shure: As long as there's one to explain.
Tasha:  把这一个
Tasha: Take this one.
Tasha:  然后掉掉成项链
Tasha: Then turn it into a necklace.
Jake: 啊这什么东西
Jake: Ah, what's this thing?
Katrina:  真的吗那是散开了
Katrina: Really? It scattered.
其他人：他那个手链的
Others: It's from his bracelet.
Katrina:  我以为是直接这样子出去了
Katrina: I thought it just fell off like that.
Lucia: 还有一个珠子
Lucia: There's another bead.
其他人：珠子还在地上
Others: The bead is still on the ground.
Katrina:  那是散开了
Katrina: It scattered.
Jake: 在地上
Jake: On the ground.
其他人：当时应应该爆开了
Others: It should have exploded at that time.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  应该是我这个东西他他压的
Shure: It should be my thing, it pressed down.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Tasha:  和我那天翻墙一样损失了一颗
Tasha: Just like the day I climbed over the wall and lost one.
Katrina:  我当时特别害怕你把眼镜甩出去了
Katrina: I was so afraid you'd throw your glasses away.
Jake: 你怎么会哦
Jake: How could you, oh.
Katrina:  我说完了
Katrina: I'm done talking.
Alice:看来捞不出来了
Alice: Looks like we can't get it out.
Alice:他竟然散的话只剩珠子吧里面
Alice: If it breaks, only the beads will be left inside.
Jake: 哎呀好疼
Jake: Ouch, that hurts.
Katrina:  那这一个串一下戴
Katrina: Should we just string this one together?
Katrina:  戴成项链吗
Katrina: Make it into a necklace?
Tasha:  嗯sorry
Tasha: Hmm, sorry.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Katrina:  我心永在
Katrina: My heart is always with you.
Lucia: （歌词）i heard so much about you
Lucia: (singing) I've heard so much about you.
其他人：你今天穿的好那种森系的感觉
Others: You look so forest-like today.
Lucia: 不行我觉得穿这外套有点热
Lucia: No, I feel a bit hot in this jacket.
Alice:森系啊
Alice: Forest style, huh?
其他人：有点像无印良品的那种风格
Others: Kind of like the Muji style.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia:（歌词） real world
Lucia: (singing) Real world.
其他人：哦是吗
Others: Oh, really?
Alice:就是一一个身上可能有五六颜色那种
Alice: It's like having five or six colors on one person.
其他人：挺好
Others: That's nice.
Alice:这是我为数不多的浅色衣服
Alice: This is one of my few light-colored clothes.
其他人：热的脸都红了太热了
Others: Your face is all red, it's so hot.
其他人：我是研一
Others: I'm a first-year grad student.
Jake:塔在哪啊看不见
Jake: Where's the tower? I can't see it.
Lucia: （歌词）force your hand
Lucia: (singing) Force your hand.
其他人：我看你们还有要给小狗
Others: I see you still have something for the puppy.
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's amazing.
Jake: 哦挺厉害
Jake: Oh, that's impressive.